Salut ! un petit peu comme on avait fait dans la vidéo du mois dernier le boost brain avec vous
sur le thème du mensonge avec Philipe Roche
On va en faire un aujourd'hui sur le thème de la mémoire
vous allez essayer de retenir en temps réel des visages et des prénoms
par exemple là ce visage il s'appelle Fabien
J’espère que vous le saviez
Et si vous le saviez pas vous pouvez vous abonner
Prenez ça pour ce que c'est, c'est à dire un jeu - un test -
mais ça va vous donner une mécanique que j'espère que vous pourrez ré-appliquer après dans la vie courante
Et soyez concentrés, ça va vite !
Certaines personnes ont du mal à retenir les prénoms des gens et d'associer le visage à ce prénom
C'est peut-être votre cas, et c'est le cas de la personne qui est avec moi
Laetitia, de la chaîne Le Corps La Maison L'esprit
On va faire un jeu ensemble où Laetitia et vous vous allez essayer de mémoriser
Sauf que vous allez être un petit peu plus armés puisque je vais vous donner trois des cinq astuces
qui sont dans le chapitre de ce livre sur "comment retenir un visage et un prénom ?"
Mais est-ce que Fabien vous a précisé que moi, je ne suis vraiment, vraiment, VRAIMENT pas capable de retenir les visages et les prénoms des gens ?
C'est d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt hein, c'est pour ça que c'est toi que j'ai invitée
Première technique qu'on va utiliser, c'est l'attention. La deuxième, c'est la mnémotechnie et (la) troisième c'est l'imaginaire.
Faites-le en même temps qu'elle et vous allez voir à la fin de la vidéo qu'en quelques minutes seulement,
vous êtes capables de retenir douze visages (et même plus d'ailleurs)
L'attention, t'es déjà en train de l'appliquer. Là forcément, puisque t'es concentré(e) [ça dépend à qui il parle] sur ce qu'on fait
Mais il va falloir qu'on fasse travailler l'imaginaire et la mnémotechnie
pour se rappeler qu'elle s'appelle Julie
-Julie Gayet *rires gênants*
C'est parfait. Vous aussi vous savez qui est Julie Gayet, et vous savez pourquoi vous connaissez Julie Gayet mieux que n'importe quelle autre Julie
C'est à cause du scooter -Exactement -L'histoire du scooter
Donc tu vas l'imaginer, Julie, avec un casque de scooter et en train de rouler sur un scooter
Le suivant il s'appelle Alexandre
Je te propose donc de l'imaginer en Roi Arthur par rapport à Alexandre Astier (NB: l'acteur qui joue Arthur dans Kaamelott)
La troisième j'ai envie que tu lui mettes une auréole au-dessus de la tête, allez-y, OREO-lez-la (rip l'humour) au-dessus de sa tête
Visualisez bien ça, parce qu'elle s'appelle Marie
Alors le suivant pour le retenir, *il imite Nicolas Sarkozy* ça va pas être trop compliqué. Pourquoi ? Bah, j'vais vous dire pourquoi.
Et donc je repense à Fabien Olicard qui fait vraiment, vraiment, VRAIMENT très mal Nicolas Sarkozy
C'est ça, tu dois l'imaginer en train de parler comme Nicolas Sarkozy
La suivante, c'est Martine. Alors vous l'imaginez à la plage, à la montagne, à la campagne, qui fait du poney (coucou les Bronies), ce que vous voulez
-Ah oui ! -Mais vous l'associez au livre "martine" -Martine -Donc tu peux l'imaginer dans un livre, tu peux l'imaginer en train de faire un château de sable
sur une couverture d'un livre. T'essayes de le faire ?
Et le suivant c'est facile, il s'appelle Pierre, donc... -Comme Pierre Croce -Exactement, pour ceux qui connaissent bien YouTube,
on va penser à Pierre Croce parce qu'en plus, il y a un p'tit air de ressemblance comme ça
alors, pour Pierre Croce -désolé Pierre si tu tombes sur cette vidéo- tu vas l'imaginer avec un bon double-menton
-Et bah j'ai pensé au double-menton parce que Pierre Croce en parle souvent dans ses vidéos -Bah ouais, c'est ça. C'est lui qui s'auto-vanne dessus.
Et si vous savez pas qui est Pierre Croce, vous pouvez imaginer une pluie de cailloux qui lui tombent sur la tête, des pierres qui lui tombent dessus.
T'essaies de me refaire tous les prénoms dans l'ordre. La première c'est qui ? -La première c'est Julie Gayet -Ouais -Donc elle s'appelle Julie -Ouais
-La deuxième, en fait c'est le Roi Arthur sauf qu'il s'appelle Alexandre -Exact
-La troisième c'est la meuf qu'on a mis enceinte, c'était Marie -Oui -Elle a pris cher -Ouais
-Le "troisième" (elle se fail) c'était le Nicolas de Nicolas Sarkozy parce que tu le fais trop mal -C'est ça et c'est le quatrième
-Exactement et c'est vachement mieux quand on sait compter. C'est mieux.
Elle, c'est Martine que j'ai appelée Marie  mais elle s'appelle Martine parce qu'en fait Martine à la plage et compagnie -Ouais
-Et lui c'est Pierre Croce donc il s'appelle Pierre *put*** j'suis trop forte* -Ok.
Vous avez besoin de retrouver quel était le prénom de la personne. Donc le fait de les avoir appris dans l'ordre maintenant, ne va plus te servir à rien.
Là je vais en faire piocher six à Laetita et vous allez essayer de deviner en même temps qu'elle
et essayer de voir combien vous faites sur 6 et vous me le mettrez dans les commentaires, et, (à Laetitia) peut-être qu'ils vont te battre
c'est pas sûr que toi tu aies bon aux six hein -Nan nan c'est pas sûr du tout même
-Vous êtes un petit peu en battle contre Laetitia
-Pardon, pardon, pardon. -Celui que tu veux
-Alors, elle, avec son petit air angélique, c'est la meuf qu'on a mise enceinte -Exactement, c'est Marie
Ah, c'est Nicolas Sarkozy -OUI! Joli, c'est Nicolas
-Attends, avec sa tête de gentil c'était euuuuuuuh.... -Ah c'est un peu plus dur -Art... -Aaaaaah !
-Oui, nan... Si c'était Arthur qui en fait s'appelle Alexandre -Exactement, j'croyais que t'allais avoir faux sur celui-ci
-Et alors lui, bien évidemment c'est Pierre Croce, donc Pierre -Oui, le double-menton, c'est Pierre
Pierre que peut-être vous, vous aviez retenu avec une chute de cailloux sur la tête on avait dit
-Valérie ? Nan, nan Valérie c'est l'autre. Elle c'est Julie Gayet ? -Là t'es en train de refaire un conflit politique
-Et bah elle, c'est la meuf qui a eu dix mille vies dans une vie donc c'est Martine - OUI !
-Je suis auto-épatée mais j'aimerais bien voir ce que ça donne dans la vraie vie
-C'est encore plus simple quand on a la personne en entier et qu'on lui demande encore plus d'informations
et qu'on a le temps de discuter un tout petit peu, ne serait-ce qu'un tout petit peu avec elle
Les deux autres clés que je ne vous avais pas données, justement, c'est la boucle phonologique, et la répétition évidemment
c'est-à-dire replacer le prénom un maximum de fois. Au lieu de lui demander "passez-moi de l'eau s'il vous plaît"
dites "passez-moi de l'eau, Martine, s'il vous plaît" QUE si la personne s'appelle Martine
Forcément, je sais pas encore combien vous avez fait. Si vous avez fait moins de 4, il est fort possible qu'il faille travailler encore plus l'attention
OU la visualisation, quand je vous dis de visualiser, essayez de le faire réellement, j'avais fait une vidéo d'ailleurs, pour ceux qui ont du mal à visualiser
Je remercie Laetitia de la chaîne Le Corps La Maison L'Esprit d'être venue, c'est la deuxième fois que je la fais venir pour un boost brain sur la mémoire,
parce que typiquement c'est une personne qui dit ne pas avoir de mémoire, et qui galère
donc à chaque fois je me dis "si elle y arrive, elle, ils vont y arriver". Vous trouverez un lien vers sa chaîne dans la description
Elle publie du contenu de tous les jours depuis plus de deux ans maintenant. Là, elle a fait tout un parcours personnel en Inde et en Asie
Donc en ce moment ça mélange un peu le voyage et le développement personnel, c'est HYPER intéressant.
Je reçois encore pas mal de questions sur le livre "Votre cerveau est extraordinaire", n'oubliez pas que j'ai fait une vidéo où je réponds à toutes les questions
C'est aussi en description. Et le livre est toujours dispo en librairies, FNAC, Amazon etc.
Avec dédicaces le 24 juin à Calligramme La Rochelle, et à côté de Caen à Montville, c'est le 28 juin et c'est à Cultura.
Et puis je vous donne un petit rendez-vous, alors on prend son papier, son crayon, ou on le note dans le téléphone,
ce sera Mercredi (21 Juin) à 17h30 la prochaine vidéo, on parlera d'argent. Ciao.